ma on va faire une machine à remonter le
temps et on va faire une interview
flash back nous sommes en 1963 bonsoir
eddy mitchell heureux de recevoir pour
soir un jeune qui débute vous avez 21
ans
alors votre vraiment tout le monde croit
que c'est claude moine en fait le vrai
vrai nom s'est clos de lucien moines à
bouchard nous aime pas non plus
puisqu'il si on veut et l'organisation
nous mais schmoll parce qu'à plusieurs
versions on dit que c'est vos copains du
golf drouot où on dit aussi que c'est
josette la valise qui croyaient que nous
au crédit lyonnais
josette ou que dont j'ai oublié le nom
qu'on appelait la valise pour des
raisons évidentes
pourquoi on appelait les rayons je
produis toujours bête comme une valise à
la main pour que je devais les mecs tu
le sais j'ai donc elles s'étaient vengés
m'appelait jim hall et chmod qui est
devenue folle voilà et c'est là que vous
avez fait les les five rocks au départ
ça plaît pas du tout les chaussettes
noires et vous êtes fait avoir un jour
vous entendez votre disque à la radio et
on nous annonce comme les chaussettes
noires vite mais c'est pas nous c'est
les pailles rocks et en fait six ou sept
ce thème qui avait racheté le groupe
d'une certaine façon n'ont pas acheté
c'est un accord commercial entre entre
eddie barclay lucien morisse qu'était
directeur de des programmes d'europe 1 à
l'époque le groupe
ce thème est aujourd'hui donc et 10 me
tienne nous commencer une carrière solo
voilà j'espère que ça a marché on va y
croire quand même temps à bah oui mais
enfin celui ci a 21 ans j'y crois pas
ouais alors que vous étiez petit ai dit
vous aviez les cheveux longs à votre
mère vous laisser pousser les cheveux et
dé xavier les cheveux plus courts disant
vous avez eu le plus mais un seizième
gestionnaire avec un toute façon vous
aviez toujours donc depuis votre plus
jeune âge les espèces de bananes
on avait vu j'ai eu beaucoup mieux et
vous allez la garder longtemps vous
pensez bah je sais pas j'ai encore
quelques années devant moi j'espère mais
je sais pas je vous le souhaite je veux
blesser alors vous chantez beaucoup de
reprises de chansons américaines
eddy mitchell est ce que vous avez pas
envie de trouver un compositeur français
oui mais c'est un produit rare disant
vous pensez vous vraiment un piia il dit
j'aimerais bien un n'êtes pas
impressionné ben oui non oui si bien sûr
parce que c'est la seule salle à paris
il y aura quoi votre avis après les
ailiers leigh gmail y âge pas
comment vous imaginez l'an 2000 est ce
que vous pensez que ras des chamois des
voitures volantes d'être un surplus
salaire à j'aimerais bien des filles
avec super de sa part de dieu par les
toques marron qui j'espère qu'on sent le
vent là est ce que vous pensez qu'un
jour vous fêterez vos quarante ans de
carrière à la télévision ça se serait
formé à mais j'y crois pas beaucoup
d'employés patrouillant vote mais vous
comptez le garder ou non je voudrais
bien jours a bien changé mais parie que
ça fait mal ça fait simplement vous
donner un conseil et dit je pense que
vous allez faire une grande carrière
personnellement mais méfiez-vous d'un
truc vous avez une tête à avoir des
coliques néphrétiques hall
méfiez-vous des coliques néphrétiques si
vous savez lire dans les yeux mais
presque normalement je ne vois pas là
alors faites bien attention à vous dire
ceci des maristes
ah oui je travaille sur mon mari social
viellissant en vieillissant il ya aussi
verra plus tard
tous les
l outil critique
extrait de son album
si la vie
michel 18 septembre au 5 octobre
halak l'a tuée en tournée dans toute la
bande
eddy mitchell